Coyote's coming off an 8-1 shellacking of Chicago
at home on Monday they are riding High a lot of
players had big Point nights in that game
puck rimmed around the boards Terry seals
the wall brings it in lets it go he scores Troy
Terry on the power play the Ducks break the ice
boy this comes out of nothing and and you know
the whole key here it's a self chip by mikov on
the entry into the zone here's mikov here's
the Chip And he follows it up and here's the
pressure so the coyotes react to that pressure
hard Rim Troy Terry's got space he says thanks
very much he'll take it and he just rips it up
top short side over top of the blocker what a
perfect shot by Troy Terry Anaheim had nothing
going on and then Anaheim will have a minute
and 39 of Power Play Time Dumba bumped oh nice
play by mikov who took him out of the play and
took the puck back now three on two Here Come
the Ducks drop pass to Fowler back to mov oh
he hit the goal post rebound score Terry has
his second of the N I thought mov initially
scored but good on Troy Terry who stayed with
it it's two nothing it starts with him making
an unbelievable defensive play gets a great
angle and look at him turn it up realized that
Dumba had dropped a stick not only does he drop
the puck but he continues going towards the net
he hits the pipe Terry mops it up for his second
of the game but a tell you what pav mikov what a
beautiful play by him and good on Troy Terry got
a goal they had a man Advantage here got to go
Mavis now turns it into a two-on-one with Terry
Mason Mavis to Terry score Patrick overtime game
winner
[Music]
the win streak reaches five but it was
the lookoff in the neutral zone by Mason
McTavish that set up the two-on-one
you're right a little stop and go
from Mavis right here watch him look up
smz and then away he goes see you later
two on one good pass and TR Terry you know
he's a right-handed shot for him to handle
that Puck and get it up top that is just one
beautiful finish from [Applause] [Music] him